[Music]
south korea is experiencing a golden age
of rapid progress and economic growth in
just 25 years the previously war-torn
country has risen to become the world's
12th largest economy
the birthplace of samsung is also one of
the world's most internet savvy nations
social media is such an important part
of korean culture that they even have
their own messaging service where
koreans send over 55 billion text
messages per day
if i was going to connect with the
korean people i would need to learn
their language
this is kim shield am i saying your name
correctly
jim shield
ginshield
i've asked you to teach me korean
and in an hour
all i've learned is how to say your name
chinchill
i'd like to learn
the culture
what is the correct way to behave may i
do i make eye contact or do i avert my
eyes at women just eye contact but not
like that
scary what i'm doing now is scary so
you're saying look at people in the eye
but not too closely you tell me when i'm
too close
i'm gonna start moving towards you and
you say whenever okay that's enough
should my expression be happy
yes
good luck
weird smile not weird
what am i doing that's weird okay
naturally naturally yeah this is my
natural smile
how do i say hello
if i walk up to a woman and say how much
i get slapped in my country
okay
joel good job that's good yeah i like it
i like this good uh
it hurt yeah
it hurt
what are you thinking i'm not why do you
think i'm thinking anything back your
thinking is
tara
dirty
my thinking is dirty
i'm repressed
repression do you know what repression
is
it's when irish catholics in america
step down
sexually
and then it comes out in strange
sometimes unappealing ways
your hands throw up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what is this
this is my stick
for a student this is just may show this
this is the stick that you use for
students
i using this for love you're using this
for love
you've got a love stick
and i'm the dirty guy you use this too
yeah actually you don't hit people do
you i sometimes are you going to do that
with me
i'll punish me with that stuff
why you like it yeah
stop liking it no no stop
okay you don't understand my entire
fantasy is a stern
woman i don't like you
you are a stern school mistress who is
unhappy and punishing me and i'm being
hurt with your love stick this is the
greatest thing that ever happened to me
oh my gosh what are you talking about
i'm not weird oh i'm weird yes you're
weird didn't you look me up on the
internet before i came here i'm famous
for being weird i'm a great egg creep
stop smiling and stop stop smiling like
moving your fingers like that what are
you talking about take a look
at my fingers don't smile you want to
write your name in korean yeah in korean
i want to write my name in korean yeah
here
do you oh okay here first okay
this is the i thought this was a menu
i swear to god this is kona this is
conan yeah that's conan right there
look at that conan yeah
so do you know how to write
do i know how to write without saying
this no i will give you three seconds
okay
i have three seconds
are they yet all the same
[Applause]
oh yes and this one too
this one too okay
you know what
it hurt
oh
this is me this actually looks a lot
like me
okay this is me and i do wear little
boys underwear
okay what's this
what that's called
this area okay chest okay
it's called
cassoon okay a nipple is
okay i'll just point to it with your
stick
should i touch it
can you just skip please no please i
need to know
i'm trying to learn
oh my god just stop it stop it doing
that more is not going to make me stop
bernie's here
where is your own donkey
i don't think nobody can teach you you
don't think anyone can teach me yeah
because too like you twist it you think
i'm twisting
like 30 things i don't think i i think i
took your lead i took your
you put out a message
with my what are these called again say
it
very good oh
and um
okay can we be friends okay is that
possible
how do i say hello friend annyeong
chingo annyeong chengu
oh
you